Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about positions in Iikido.
So, I'm going to talk to you guys about
the primary positions and I I'm pretty
sure I've made a video on that before,
but we're going to go back over what the
primary positions are, what a is, what
the secondary positions are, and what
the tertiary positions are, and how
those naturally lead to a progression of
what the techniques are in Iikido. um
outside of uh some of the stuff that's
the the more joint specific stuff you
might call it consetsu waza or has a lot
of the kilowaza stuff. So how the
nagwaza plays out from those positional
orientations it'll make more sense when
I show it to you. I'm going to get Josh
out here. We're going to go to work.
Josh. All right. So let's talk about
positions a secondary positions tertiary
positions and technique and how that all
interplays. So, I'm pretty sure I've
made a video guide for you guys before
about primary positions, but let's just
quickly review what the primary
positions are. Now, these are not
tinoinko. These are not how I get to the
positions. These are just the positions
that we talk about in iikido. So, the
first position is muhani. And that means
without hanmi. So, I don't have a hanmi
here. And the reason we refer to it that
way is because in iikido you should
always have hanmi. So, if you're in a no
hanmi situation, your primary objective
is to get hanmi at least, right? So,
hanmi would be either going this side or
this side. and we start to get a half
body position. If I were to move like
this, it's Iani because my left foot is
closest to his left foot and his left
foot's closest to mine. So by just
stepping, we don't have to change
anything. By just stepping like this, we
already have Ihani. Now, of course, the
same would be true on the other side. If
I step this way, I just have Iani on the
other side. So this would be U Migi Ian,
right side me Ian. Okay. Now, if I
rotate slightly like this, then I get
right. So if I'm trying to get off the
line and I go like this, that's now
gakuhani because his left foot's forward
and my right foot's forward. That's gaku
opposite. And of course, if I did the
same thing to the other side, that would
just be yakuhani over there. Right? So
there's our eye and gaku hani. Now those
positions are okay. They're better than
this position. This is the worst
position.
But is the next position up, right? And
for that, of course, we have yaku. We're
facing opposite directions. And I we're
facing same direction. And if you want
to get technical about a technique, you
could also have choku, which is 90
degrees to each other. So also you can
say that. And then the best position for
us is edimi. And we either have i edimi,
we're facing the same direction, choku
edimi, we're 90° to each other, or um
yaku edimi, we're facing opposite
direction of each other. Okay. So those
are the basic positions. And as we get
to the back position, they're improving
every time, right? So so you know this
position's not that good. This
position's slightly better. This
position's better yet. Right? So, we're
getting better and better and better as
we start to go around. Okay? So, when
I'm dealing with this guy in time and
space, I'm always trying to get to a
better and better position. Right? So,
imagine if we were at far distance. If I
could get around to the back of this
guy, then that's exactly what I would
try to do. You know, if he wasn't paying
attention to me or too slow or whatever,
I'm going to I'm going to work my way
behind him because he can do very little
to me if I'm behind him, much less than
he could do if I'm right in front of
him. Right? So, that's what I'm doing.
Okay? So that's the beginning idea of a
was. I'm blending with him, right? So
I'm making some kind of interaction with
him and trying to get a good position
for myself. Now, as I'm moving, if he's
chasing me down, of course, he's going
to adapt. So meaning if he was coming at
me, you got to go ultra ultra slow right
now, but if he's coming at me and I
start to go over here, he's going to of
course adapt. And now we have Muhani
again, right? You see, because I moved
over here and he moved over here, we
have Muhani. So most of the time when
you're starting to make a was with them,
they're just going to keep adjusting to
you. And so you'll always be in Muhani
and you're going to keep trying to get
out of Muhani and they're going to keep
trying to put you in Muhani because they
want you right in front of them so they
can get you. Right? So that's the
beginning of a was now as we get closer
and closer and closer. If we're in
Muhani, I'm going to try and get a
secondary awas, right? Or a secondary
position, right? And that's going to
come through our tino, right? So imagine
we right now we're going to put his
hands out really simply right out in
front of him. I'm going to try to get a
stoi, which puts me in hitoi, right? I'm
going to try to get an edi which puts me
in eimi. Right. I'm going to try to get
any one of those tiny hinka we talk
about all the time. 45s 90s triangles
all that stuff. Okay. Now, as I do that,
if he can, he's going to adapt to that
in some way. Now, there's really only
three ways he's going to adapt. So,
understand because we have suppression
here. I have his arm suppressed. He can
really only go over my
suppression, under my suppression, or
pull his hand back. Right? So, that's
basically how he's going to deal with my
suppression somehow. He actually can't
as long as I have a nice light body,
push into my suppression because if he
does that, I just move my body, right?
And I stay suppressed the whole time or
he stays suppressed the whole time as
I'm moving with him, right? So, he's
going to have to do one of those three
things. Now, I predicts to us that if he
goes up, I should try and stay stuck and
I get echo with it, right? So, Eko comes
out really naturally if he goes up.
Okay? If he pulls his hand back, I
should try and stay stuck to his hand,
right? So that takes care of itself in
its own way. Now, if he goes around, we
start to have a lot of difficulty.
That's going to be the easiest and best
way for him to re-engage with me is just
to bring his arm down and around like
that. And that's what he's looking for.
Okay. Now, if he gets me there, I'm in a
really bad way. So, anytime I'm in that
position, I should either try to uh
shoot through and we'll count that just
as one of our secondary or a tiny hinko
to get to our secondary positions,
right? Or I have to shoot a triangle
because he's come around. I can't get
underneath. Boom. I'm going to have him
go like this. Okay. So, actually, let's
shoot to the other side. So, so we're
here as he goes around underneath. Yep.
Boom. There. And I pop out to this
position right here. So, now I'm in a
nice triangle position. Let's angle you
this a little bit. Okay. So, now we're
into all of our tertiary position. So,
this is our third positions that will
lead to technique. So, this inside
position is like the third and final
kind of variation on this. His arms are
wide. He's coming to get me. I have my
hand in his face and I'm trying to deal
with this. So, what's he going to do
from this? Well, he could just keep
trying to charge in and get me. Bang.
Just like this. Okay. Now, that really
directly leads to a
koshag, right? So, we get a kosh. Okay.
Mic problem. No problem. But Josh
grabbed my lapel mic. No problem. Okay.
So, that leads directly to a koshi nag,
right? Okay. If he keeps coming and
trying to go around this, this leads to
kiteen. And if he goes underneath, we
get a classic kite nag. But it's just
the concept of kiteen. And I think
that's an important distinction is to
not think about the kiten as being like
kiteen nag. Although if he goes lower
and lower lower trying to get around my
suppression. Why I'm saying that is like
so I have my hand in his face. Where's
he going to put his head if he wants to
get to me? Watch. See he dropped his
head, right? So if he drops his head and
I drop my hand and he drops his head and
I drop my hand, he drops his head and I
drop my hand. We get kitanag. Not cuz I
push his head down but because he's
trying to slip his head down underneath
and around me, right? So that's what
he's up to. So that will often lead to a
kitanag like that. But just the kite is
how I'm dealing with that tertiary
position. Right? So I'm here. When Josh
comes in towards me, this is just how
I'm dealing with it. Right? That is just
that that turning around action is just
how I'm dealing with it. Now, if he
doesn't want to just spin with me, he's
going to engage and that will probably
lead to a kitenag. But that's what that
kiten position is, right? Okay. Other
than that, what am I going to do? Well,
I'm going to get this arm down somehow
so I can start to come through, right?
And so this is gate on barai, that low
sweep like that. And then that could
become this kind of blend. it could turn
into a silt moari and we get all the
other techniques from that right so
these the techniques naturally arise
because he keeps giving me a problem
with what I initially want to do right
so think of it it's real simple I want
to not be in front of him so I'm going
to move somewhere now if he let me move
somewhere and didn't do anything and
Josh kept coming forward he would miss
me and that would be fantastic right now
we know that's almost certainly not
going to happen so from my primary
position attempt he's going to adjust
right and he's going to keep doing that
I'm going to go to a prim primary
position. He's going to adjust. I'm
going to go to a primary position. He's
going to adjust. So that's our beginning
aas. That's going to get all the way
down very likely to we're in this inside
position and I'm starting to blend with
him. So I actually have to get full aas
here with suppression and I'm going to
make some kind of blend like this. Now
if I can make that blend successfully,
he'll blow by me again. So he's coming
in and I go like this. Boom. And I made
a successful sto. Bang. And he flies off
and that's fantastic. Okay. So all of
those setups are how the techniques
naturally arise. So, we have our primary
positions. He's always going to be
wanting to put me in a muhan me and I'm
always going to try to work behind him
to get to Ihan me. So, if I could just
magically get my way, I would be back
there. If he could magically get his
way, I would never move from here. Now,
we're going to have some kind of
negotiation in between that, right? So,
as he comes to get me, I'm going to
change positions. He's going to adapt to
me. I'm going to change positions. He's
going to adapt to me. Right? And this is
how we would get basic movement
happening. So, I keep trying to get to
one of those primary better positions.
Josh keeps trying to erase that with
Muhani. Now, that's going to happen all
the way until we get right up next to
each other. And then I'm going to get my
my secondary positions, which are these
really strong like, you know, so this is
a really strong Hito and me, right? And
I'm going to get that off of my basic
tino. So, I'm going to suppress this guy
and I'm going to move with him and I'm
going to get that. Now, if he couldn't
adjust to that blend, then he would just
fly by me. So, he's coming in, I go like
this. Boom. And he couldn't adjust. He
would just fly off of me and we'd be
back to the first game we were playing,
right? So primary positions are at that
extended range. Secondary positions are
in that up close range. Now if he can
adapt to my secondary position attempt,
then we're going to get the tertiary
position, which is pretty much going to
be an the worst one is this inside wide
arm position. Right? So if I try to go
to the outside and he shoots that arm
low, I'm going to go here. So I have a
triangle right now. Everything else that
happens, all the iikido techniques that
happen happen from that. Right? So it's
going to happen in some way coming off
of that setup. So, um, I hope this video
makes sense because the mic fell off a
couple times and and we had to restart.
But, so I hope that made sense to you
guys. If it didn't make sense, let me
know and I'll make a better video for
you explaining it. But you have to
understand that everything's always done
in a series of they're going to do
something. I'm going to try this.
They're going to adapt to me or not. If
they don't adapt to me, then cool. The
thing I tried worked. If not, then I
have to have new answers for them
adapting to me. And that's going to go
all the way on until one person gets
their way or we have a resolution of
some sort, right? So, uh, that's that
for that video. I'm Christopher Fine.
This is Joshua Teheam behind that camera
right there.